How do you go about decrypting ciphered
traffic that uses these Enigma machines?
Can you do it by hand? And what actually
happened at Bletchley Park - what,
historically, was the order in which things
took place? This has been very much
prompted by the appearance of the film
called "The Imitation Game"
with Benedict Cumberbatch as Alan Turing
[ALAN TURING: ... I'm afraid these men would
only slow me down ...]
[STEWART MENZIES: ... popular at School were you ?]
Two of the first people through the doors
of Bletchley Park,
in Sept '39, were Alan Turing
and his colleague at Cambridge, another
mathematician, called Gordon Welchman,
who I think was was a year ahead of Alan Turing,
actually, in taking the Maths Tripos and of
course getting a First.
You will find throughout this story
Bletchley Park was full
of first-class mathematicians.
Even before war broke out the Allies
had had a big success
in that a German spy had actually defected,
before the war started, and handed over a
military Enigma machine
and a starter Enigma codebook-
what better tutorial?! I think he handed
it over to the French Secret Service.
The French contacted
the English, who by that stage had moved
to Bletchley Park.
Their chief cryptanalyst was a guy
called Dilly Knox who'd had a lot of
success with this stuff - going back
to the First World War.
But I mean, to cut a long story short, the
French and the British initially
dithered. They just
did not want to do ... know what to do ...
with this stuff;
war hadn't yet broken out. But fortunately
the French, I think, passed it on
under conditions of great secrecy, to the
Polish Cipher Bureau
and we, and Bletchley Park, owed them a lot because
they had a team there led by a very, very
good mathematician, called Marian Rejewski.
He spotted straightaway that with all of this system of
rotors, reflectors
plugboards it was basically just running
through the permutations.
So what better way to really get to
grips with all of this, and all of its
possibilities,
than to have somebody who was an expert in
what's called the theory of
Permutation Groups, and Marian
Rejewski was very good from that point
of view. They were dealing with machines
where there were just three rotors -
six combinations. No choices of 3 out of 5
at that stage,
and that made life a lot simpler.
A plug-board did come along and
the Poles, originally, found that they
could invent
what you might call "by hand" methods. They used
the method of perforated sheets
and amazingly by sliding these over one another
and perforating them according to the
ciphertext that you had received ....
but as it became more and more
complicated it really did
need some machinery and full credit to
the Poles,they realized this
and they built a a machine called the
Bomba. And with the Bomba
so long as it was only three wheels, so long
as there weren't too many cross-settings
on the plug-board, on input and output,
and so long as the initial message setting
was transmitted in a way that got banned
by the end of 1938, because the Germans
realized it was not very secure.
Essentially you chose
a three-letter word and you sent it twice.
And even though it appeared at the other end
as six cryptographically mapped symbols - you
know, you might type in UNS,
the German word, so you type it in twice
UNS UNS and it would appear as
LJQWXZ - something like that. Nevertheless
if you knew that those first six letters had
to map into a repeated German
three-letter word
boy, did it cut down the number of settings
of the Enigma that could possibly have
produced that! So with all those
simplifications and weaknesses the Poles were
able to make a very good start.
What really blew them out of the water, first of all,
was tragically being invaded, of course,
by Germany. How can you run a cipher bureau,
or any sort of operation, when
your country is being invaded ?
But, even prior to that, the idea of choosing
3 out of 5 before
you arrange the three on the spindle, as
we've seen, that led to 60 combinations.
They'd need not six Bombi, but sixty Bombi.
Out of the question - couldn't afford it.
Pressure in Poland was such that
they'd probably never get around to building
them anyway.
The handing over of the whole situation - as
to where the
Polish Bomba had got to - got Bletchley Park off
to a flying start.
I mean clearly they were up against
bigger plug-boards; not just three out of
five rotors
but, looking at the Naval stuff coming along,
it was looking like three out of eight.
The whole idea of
machinery was an excellent one, but it
had to be made even more
powerful and robust. It was driven by
Alan Turing
and, of course, as we now know, he was probably
one of the ideal persons to do it.
Not only was he a theoretical
mathematical logician,
while he was at Princeton he'd actually
built hardware. He loved
soldering relays together, making his
own little replicas of how his
Turing Machines might work.
As people will tell you, Andrew Hodges in
in the biography says he was 'ham-fisted'.
He was enthusiastic but not good at it.
Shaun Wylie his colleague in Hut 8 said
"Very enthusiastic
but he was so clumsy".  He used to insist
on using high-voltage soldering irons because
they were more efficient, and he'd give
himself electric shocks -
and if it wasn't electric shocks making him
scream, he'd burnt himself.
No. Enthusiasm, but not
the person you would want to build your
home computer. He
said, look, we've got to do this by
building a Bombe. Let's call it a B-O-M-B-E,
partly as a nod in the direction of the Poles and
saying "Thank you".
He drew up a specification of what needed to
be done. You see this in action in
"The Imitation Game":
[ALAN TURING: I'm designing a machine that will allow us
to break every message, every day, instantly]
But the good thing, of
course, in the movie, is that it
doesn't have to produce any results. It
just has to rotate a lot
and look very, very impressive. Thanks to a
superb effort at
what is now the Bletchley Park Museum
they have actually rebuilt
a Bombe - and it works. But let's just explain
that for
every vertical column of three in
this decryption device
the top one here. on the Bombe, corresponds to
the rightmost
drum - the fastest one. The middle one
corresponds to the middle one
and the bottom one of the three, in any
column, corresponds to the leftmost
drum which was rotating
slowest of all. Essentially what you've got
is lots and lots of
Enigmas in parallel, as it were. And you
can try out
different 'menus', as they were called -
different programs basically - saying "Well
you see that Enigma replica at the top
left. I'd like to make the
top drum be a Type II drum; the middle
one be a Type V and the bottom one be a
Type III,
because I think that was the drum ordering. And
on those drums I'd like to make the
ring settings - you know where you put
your little stud
to do the initial offset. I'd like to
make them - reading from the top -
V, A and H. Can you do that please?"
Oh! and this is where Turing's
ideas came in - he said "Look, y'know,
we are going to have to get more and more
and more
into the idea of decrypting by
trying to use known
plaintext". You know, if you're listening
in to a certain
weather station that's sending out Enigma
code, you know that phrases like "storm"
and "heavy rain" and stuff are going to occur.
Sometimes you wouldn't succeed,
you know, you'd have to give up and say "No I
think the idea was wrong, we'll have to
try something else."
The fact that Enigma never
enciphered anything to itself was a
huge help. If you look at James Grime's video
you can see him using pieces of paper
tape, as it were,
to show ciphertext and showing some
guessed plaintext underneath it.
And you slide them along and you keep on
trying different positions
and if, at a given position, a letter in
the ciphertext exactly corresponds to a
letter in the plaintext, than that cannot
be right.
You can't have an A encrypting
as an A. So you must keep
sliding it along - this guessed plaintext
- and you might stand a chance at the
places where
there are no correspondences - there's no
places where a letter is encrypted to itself.
And I think one of the stories told was
that they sent out an RAF plane
to bomb a crucially important light buoy
at the mouth
of a harbour, yeah, and they knew
which station would be reporting that
back to headquarters,
listened to the ciphertext looking
for - I think
the German word is something like 'Erleutaschtonne'
for light buoy [actually: "Erloschen ist Leuchtonne"]
and if you see something saying, y'know,
"The light buoy has been destroyed",
Wonderful! You've got known plaintext.
Now, at Bletchley
the house itself was nowhere near big
enough to accommodate
all of the personnel that were needed. It wasn't
just cryptanalysts and mathematicians it was
service personnel, intelligence people, clerks,
admin - all that stuff. So as well as
occupying the entirety of the house,
out in the grounds there were various
Huts. And different
units, with different tasks, were in
different Huts.
The 3-rotor Army and Air Force
Enigma service was based in Hut 6. It was
run by Gordon Welchman,
Turing's near-contemporary at Cambridge.
The bigger problem, the much harder
problem, was
Naval Enigma. As we have already discovered
Naval Enigma didn't just choose three rotors
out of five. It chose three rotors out of
eight -  massively complicating things.
And then Doenitz, the head of the German Navy
being yet more suspicious, and wanting his
codes to be super-secure,
introduced the idea of a fourth rotor. I
think that was particularly so for the U-boat
traffic. Now that was a much harder
problem - so for a long time
3-rotor Enigma could almost go into
production.  4-rotor Enigma
was still at the research stage. And for
some desperate months. I think in
late '41, early '42, there was a time when
Naval Enigma was off the air completely.
They just couldn't get into it and they
couldn't decrypt anything.
I think they were helped eventually by
a 'pinch', which was
to get a codebook off a submarine that
had been depth charged.
[NEWSREEL: " ... depth charges fly out over
the ocean. Shattered by depth bombs the stricken
raider is abandoned. One of dozens that are meeting
the same fate"]
And gradually as their skills built up
they were more and more successful with
Naval Enigma.
But I think you could say - even right to
the end of the war - it was always harder
than doing the Army and the Air Force
stuff. So, what it came down to, then,
at Bletchley, was
Hut 6: 3-rotor Enigma.
Hut 8: Naval
4-rotor or 3-rotor
Enigma - all done in Hut 8 under
Alan Turing. Now - when you now look at
"The Imitation Game" you will notice that it's
all centred around Hut 8.
Massive simplification! They merge Hut
6 personnel in with Hut 8 personnel;
they mention Hugh Alexander the double
British Chess Champion - quite right,
he was there with Alan Turing in Hut 8.
They mention this wonderful extension
to the back of the Bombe, called a Diagonal
Board, which helped a lot.
It was a bright idea and the implication
is given in "The Imitation Game"
that this was invented by
Hugh Alexander. No it wasn't! It was
invented by Gordon Welchman
of Hut 6, but this is Hollywood for you.
You have to live with this.
Yes, there was a guy called Jack Good in
Hut 8, you'll see him in the movie as
well. He was a very good statistician,
almost as good as Alan Turing himself,
and was also good at chess, but not as
good as Hugh Alexander.
And yes, Joan Clarke, it's not an artificial
"Oh! we must have a woman in this, let's
make one up".
No, she really existed. She also had a first-class
Maths degree from Cambridge. She went to the
women's College, Newnham,
but Gordon Welchman, I think, had been
one of her tutors, or one of her
lecturers, and thought highly of her.
So again - spoiler alert! - inside
"The Imitation Game"
Joan Clarke did not get recruited as a
result of doing a crossword puzzle
in 5 minutes and 34 seconds. She got recruited
because Gordon Welchman and Alan Turing knew
all about her
and just took great care to get hold of
her. They started building
machines with the help of a very
talented hardware engineer
called 'Doc' Keen - or Harold Keen to give
him his proper name.
You had to work out the wheel
combinations and the wheel ordering
first of all.
You needed Bombe time to try them out and
in the early days
Doc Keen did his best and made, I think, Bombes
that could be used for either 3-rotor or 4-rotor work.
Hut 6 needed them all the time for
production work,
y' know, they pretty well knew what the
settings were it was straightforward but
they needed Bombe time.
[SEAN: When you say "production work" in that instance
you're talking about just day-to-day decoding?]
Day-to-day decoding
we know we're going to crack this, y'know, we'll
just send it through and
just double check that this is right.
But, y' know, with the Army and
Air Force stuff
they were never in any serious doubt
that, from about late '41 onwards, they
could do it.
What you didn't want was the Hut 8 mob
coming in and saying
"It's our turn on that machine now - it's
not fair, we're meant to share these things!"
The problem for Hut 8, you see, was that their
usage was a lot more speculative -
it would lead to a lot more failures until
you got some idea
of what the wheel ordering was. And then
Alan Turing came up with a really
very, very bright idea, which showed how good
a statistician he was.
What he said was: "Look we could maximize our -
what's the word? - payoff, from these Bombes
if only we knew, without getting on to
the things,
which wheels were in use at the right and
the middle.
Those are the ones that are going to rotate
first. You know, you feed in your first
bit of ciphertext,
it's the right one that goes round 26 times.
And then
the next one starts to move. So by the
time you've done
six hundred and - whatever 26 squared is -
characters,
you've seen a fair bit of ciphertext.
If you take that ciphertext and think
that it came from German,
but with certain wheel settings on
the right and the middle - but we don't
know them yet -
what do you know from the frequency
statistics of letters
in German as to how that might
give itself away a little bit
even in ciphertext, depending on exactly
what the cross
wirings were in the right and
middle rotors. In other words, could we
say that a number I and a number III
rotor, that we're trying here,
matches this vague matching process
rather better than a number V and a
number II ?
Those of you who know some statistics will
realise this is Conditional Sequential
Bayesian Probabilities.
And all that happened when you convoluted,
as it were, arbitrary German text with
this ciphertext, is certain little
indications would come out.
They didn't do it on the Bombe, they did
it by another method of
sheets. And their sheets were made in Banbury.
You punched holes in sheets and put them
over a lightbox, and
slid one over the other. And you looked
at these great long strings of stuff
coming out with certain little groupings
of letters there that were giving the game
away statistically.
It turned out that it was deadly work.
You had to concentrate
and yet not fall asleep. And you had to
remember what had gone before; you had to
try and think what might come up. I don't
understand all the
details but I'm not surprised in the
slightest to find that
the person who was best at spotting this
was Hugh Alexander,
the chess champion. And by common consent
in Hut 8
he was the best. Probably the next best
- second equal I
think - was Jack Good, also a statistician
and a good chess player but -  I don't play
chess -
Hugh Alexander was Top Board at Bletchley.
Jack Good
was Fourth Board. Right? Those two.
But I think Hugh Alexander thought the world
of Joan Clarke. He thought that possibly Joan
and Jack were the next best, after him, at decoding
using this Alan Turing technique which,
because it used sheets made in Banbury,
was inevitably given the Latinised name
of Banburismus.
But it was helpful, because if you did it
properly
you could say: "We can reduce
the time on the Bombe, when we get on to
it, because we know that
this ciphertext, really, has almost
certainly come
from having a number V in the middle
and the number I on the right.
So all we've got to do is to work out
what this left rotor is.
[SEAN: So just as a very rough kind of instance
of that might be something like
we know E comes up more than any ...]
Exactly!
[SEAN: ... other letter and it's probably been turned into an L ...]
... been turned into an L and and all sorts of things.
But knowing the cross-wirings of those
two that you're assuming, you could work
out how the pattern of heavy Es would
come out into certain other patterns that
would give the game away, but only ever
so slightly. It would look
almost random - but not quite. And you had
to be trained how to spot
the non-randomness. What helped a lot, of
course, was when they started building
more Bombes.
And even for production work from
[Hut 6 and] Hut 3,
there was no way that the Bombes they could
build at Bletchley Park were enough. They had
to start putting them out in
other derelict manor houses, within about
a 20 mile radius. They ended up I think
by the beginning of  '42 with about 3 other
manor houses full of Bombes; eventually 6 by
the end of the war.
I think the overall estimates are that there
were about 40 or 50 Bombes, of various
sorts, in the UK.
When you add it how many there were,
built in America -
because that was the other factor. The plans
for these were handed ouver to the Americans -
Special Relationship, all that - taken to
America
and with American not being under daily air
raids and having no shortage of raw materials,
they built, I think in the end, something
approaching a couple of hundred
Bombes of various sorts. And the interesting
story is that in late
'42 early '43, I think it was, Alan
Turing made a
journey to America and went to see the
Naval decryption operation, and also the
the Army one as well, because they were
separate in America - not under
a combined roof as there were at Bletchley -
and I think the Naval admirals were really,
right at the start of the war, y'know,
very worried saying: "We can build this
machinery but
you know we're up against it. We've
got Doenitz against us
and he's 3 out of 8, not 3 out of 5.
Now, our mathematician people tell us
3 out of 8
turns out to be 336. OK, Alan! So here's
the deal -
we've got to build 336 of these Bombes,
haven't we?"
And Alan said: "No -- you don't! You use my
Banburismus
technique, to sort out which
rotors you almost certainly have got - off
the Bombe - before you ever get on it, and
then you can make do.
And I think they thought this was
wonderful. I think in the end they built -
I don't know what the compromise was - to
build somewhere between 60 and 100 rather than
336. But so highly
did they think of this technique - the Americans -
that there's a very interesting story.
That conditional sequential Bayesian
probability, Banburismus,
technique has been classified from then
until 2010. That's how sensitive it was.
The reason that made it even more
sensitive was that it wasn't just used in
4-rotor Naval Enigma, where it was
important but it
fed on into the other machine that we are going
to do a separate video about at some stage,
the well-known Colossus
machine. That technique was of great use there
as well.
One final indication of how they got on
top of the problem - again from Hugh Alexander.
With use of the Banburismus techniques
the sheets, and extra Bombe time - that was
the point -
everybody wanted Bombe time, they
eventually got enough
and what Alexander said -- and I had no
idea this took place -- he said:
"You do realise,  of course, they
weren't all physically in England?
We had dedicated transatlantic
underwater cables between us and
the NCR place which was doing
Naval Enigma
in the USA.  So they were very nice. We
didn't have to ship any of their machinery over
to us, which we would have never been
allowed to do
but what we did was we just sent our
jobs over to them -
the ones that we didn't have the Bombe
time to do - we could send them the menu
- the settings on the Bombe plugboard that
enable you
to set up the drums to be of a certain type,
and in a certain order,
and ring settings and all that, so the full spec.
for that menu
(which we would call a 'program' nowadays),
could be sent over the undersea cable
and the result usually came back within
an hour". And that made a huge difference
to the amount of traffic that they could get
on top of. So it's sobering to
reflect that
just over seventy years ago now,
rather than undersea fibre-optic, or
anything like that,
even on good old-fashioned undersea
copper cables
you were still sending programs
into the Cryptographic Cloud, as it were,
at the other side of the Atlantic.